cabeza la cabeza Ladell nephrons
superfluous
this is my music this challenge of the
potential to change the European Union
we have built it have the potential even
to destroy it the best way to welcome to
summer agenda if there was ever a time
to give the speech of your life can miss
young could deliver an action plan to
stop the disintegration of Europe
following the shock result of the UK
referendum a year on from his maiden
State of Union address growth remains
stagnant and real solutions are still
lacking on migration and now even bigger
threats have emerged the shadow of
terrorism stalks Europe's capitals and
the UK's decision to quit the European
Union could have a monumental impact on
the very fabric of the European project
in his speech to be delivered after the
summer break that you commissioned
president was set out the Commission's
2017 priorities reform is needed but
will it come if ever heard of you can
cause anything and I'll show blue that
be you say enacted Dublin the new puppy
30 IT accorded
well one thing that's not going to
change because of a potential brexit the
UK is a 5 billion euro contribution to
the 2017 new budget scheduled to be
presented to any piece in May but
delayed to July the 1st the 134 point
nine billion euro budget will focus on
the economy and tackling the migration
crisis here are some facts and figures
ten point six billion here as we put
into research and development under
horizon 2020 two billion will be
earmarked for asthma's plus five point
two billion euros we spent to reinforce
external borders and address the
migration crisis any piece will start
negotiations on the 2017 budget in
autumn we need to speed up with your
firearms directive this is Kane first
like us and what of the director
following multiple terrorist attacks in
Paris and then later on in Brussels
plans are underway to upgrade laws on
gun control but can the European
Parliament steer the legislation in the
right direction to ensure that it can
fight terrorism full throttle and not
affect the ones of the legal gun owners
at the end of mass tear the EU executive
detailed proposals to existing firearms
legislation the main aims to stop two
types of semi-automatic weapons
deactivated guns and Kalashnikovs are
falling into the wrong hands
but the proposed changes won't in
themselves tackle the black-market so
you will questions be raised over the
legislation's ability to be used as a
tool to tackle terrorism fully when it
goes to plenary for the first time
they'd be special lubricant which make
the car move better they disconnect the
battery a lot of young people they feel
cheated not just because of the
Volkswagen scandal glibly 11 million
cars are affected by Volkswagens diesel
jeep where they manipulated car missions
testing data to make their cars appear
cleaner than they actually were what
comes next
stricter emissions test for all new cars
will be introduced from September 2017
from the Parliament side they set up an
investigative committee the emission
measurements in the automotive sector
ennis and with their mandate almost up
they will present their final report at
the end of the year and now for the
missing brief a new regulation to
improve the labeling and quality of
organic products is in the final stages
of negotiation idea with member states
should be finalized by the end of the
year a final plenary vote awaits the
agreement on a liberalization of
passenger rail travel in the EU
currently the legislation is awaiting
approval from member states a deal to
overhaul the quality of medical devices
has been done but the final confirmation
vote will take place just before
Christmas attempts to make our
lifestyles less disposable by making one
man's waste another's new mobile phone
takes a step closer to reality at the
end of the year the Environment
Committee will vote on all four circular
economy reports waste landfill of waste
packaging of waste and end-of-life
vehicles
and finally at the end of the year award
season hits the Parliament
in the autumn public screenings will
begin of the film's shortlisted for Lux
film price which celebrates European
cinema in November at the plenary the
winning Lux film will be announced and
at the December plenary it'll be the
turn to unveil the recipient of
Parliament's Sakharov Prize for freedom
of thought it honors an individual or
group of people that have fought for
human rights and to fight oppression and
that's all we have this agenda take care
and enjoy the summer